you've been very outspoken about what
happened at the election and the new
administration Sean Spicer baked potato
guy huh just happened a few hours ago
you have been following you you say you
like to watch on Spicer's news
conferences almost like their
entertainment well it's just like he's
so stupid he can't he can't possibly be
that stupid naturally like I believe
that Donald Trump right before he goes
out there he's like say something about
thought like hey say about Hitler I say
something about Hitler and then yeah and
the Holocaust say something about that
and then Sean Spicer was like you know
in the middle of diarrhea pulling his
pants off he's like I need to go out
there and just like lie
on the daily over and over and over
again I I think he has to I think Trump
whispers in his ear and then Sean Spicer
runs out he's like I mean even Hitler
didn't use chemical weapons it's like
you know cuz he was such a great guy
yeah I mean it was a strange moment the
press comes today I think just before we
went on the air he apologized for that
whatever that means nothing at this
point I mean every day he he's I mean I
don't understand you know how you can
keep that job and go out there and do
that like does he think this is gonna
end well for him like all of a sudden
he's gonna get a huge promotion cuz
people are gonna beg he's amazing
he's gone down right you are I don't
know I talked about this before the show
everyone in the administration is saying
and doing kooky things so it's hard to
isolate one person and say they're the
ones that's going down you know what I
mean it is why Sean Spicer because he's
the spokesperson so like he actually is
telling different lies every day and
contradict and getting in fights
I also wish I was in that press room so
I could get up and be like how do you
feel about working for this man who says
one thing on Wednesday and another thing
on Friday and actually ask him questions
that you can prove that he lied about
you know instead they're like they ask
him serious questions as if he's got a
answer you doesn't know what he's to say
he doesn't know what he's talking about
you've been very outspoken about Ivanka
Trump what's your beef there that she's
in that family
that she hasn't divorced herself
publicly from her father as a woman I
would never let my father run for
president knowing what I know about my
father that brings up a whole other can
of worms my father was not even half as
bad as Donald Trump you know because
he's not it's like a thing you've ever
said about yeah I saw my dad recently a
couple weeks ago in New York or
Pennsylvania he's living in Pennsylvania
now at one of those like home health
cares he's actually really cute my dad
yeah and he's he's still alive that's
the second nicest thing you've said
about it he's 86 and I was looking at
him I'm like I really hope I don't make
it to 86 because it's just you know it's
a long haul this suddenly went down a
road I did
you